[Applause]
here's some video of the protest at the
tree last
[Music]
night all right let's not even bother
with Fox News here Fox News happens to
be there this was about the tree they
called it flood the tree lighting so
it's you know as somebody has said on
Twitter it's now getting uh quoted all
over the place I don't know who came up
with the line originally maybe we can
find it is they come for the Saturday
people first and then they go for the
Sunday people and that's what's
Happening Here I have said it all along
if you think this ends with the Jews
they are they are imagine if this was
any other situation right imagine if
this was during Ramadan and a bunch of
Christ masked Christians and Jews with
crazy signs and everything else were
protesting at a mosque right how would
the reaction be but I'm seeing a lot of
quietness from people who would usually
be outraged because people don't know
what to do about this and by the way it
was a riot it was not peaceful and yes
there were calls for genocide and there
were swastikas out there and more uh
here's just a little bit of one of the
braws with the New York police officers
who by the way although many of them um
they don't they seemingly don't do their
job I have a lot of sympathy for whoever
is left and it's an unwinable untenable
situation because they have a horrible
mayor and they are being told to stand
down all the time so occasionally they
get into situations like
[Music]
[Applause]
this
I have simply no doubt that guy that was
res resisting arrests or fighting with
the cops is not in jail right now like
there's just no I have no evidence we
checked this morning that anyone got
arrested there now I want to just show
you one more because if you think that
they are not brazenly abusing whatever
laws I mean they're not even laws
anymore if no one if no one behaves like
they're laws then they're not laws in
these blue uh these blue cities um but I
want to show you one more check check
this one out tell me if this behavior is
legal I I'm not a legal expert maybe we
can get someone online but tell me if
this seems like you know this should be
allowed in a in a functioning Society
what do you want you what do you want I
can't hear you what do you
want what do you
want
[Applause]
that is a police officer's hat a member
of the NYPD once the most respected
Police Department quite literally in the
world that was stolen from him maybe it
fell off but in essence stolen might
have fallen off in a m but stolen from
him lit on fire uh and then a guy
dressed like a cobra Soldier and Cobra
were the bad guys in GI Joe uh then
brought it out to the middle of the
street and dropped it there and then of
course all the you know the mob of
reporters and reporters I don't know
what they are these people that just
come around and film everything so
there's several laws that were broken
there nobody will do anything about it
and I tweeted it out right before the
show this is a good litmus test for New
York City and for Eric Adams and the New
York Police Department someone can
identify that guy if you cannot at least
arrest that guy then I I truly mean this
with with no sarcasm or hyperbole or
anything else then if you are a sane
person you must leave New York City now